okay what a year what you personal you
look fabulous we've got a little make a
middle in the dress we love this you
always show you what a year it's an
amazing year working with my incredible
friends and incredible filmmakers and
colleagues all here tonight very
exciting and what has it meant to you
the way people have launched or lurched
and lurched launched onto your onto your
character and marriage story it's like a
love/hate well I think you know that's
exactly what it is I mean I think that's
what Noah does so beautifully he shows
all the sides of every single character
in his films and she's a divorce lawyer
it can't be easy but she wins two
kickers sorry I just start running my
mouth so glad you're here because as you
in yeah I've been asking people all
night because I keep hearing about big
little lies you said absolutely not and
you said it could happen so now that you
say absolutely no when did I say
absolutely not no no I said definitely
just not now Laura has no time this is
my publicist Nicole Kidman and my best
friend and then I said I would never say
no to Renata and they're like flowers
really said see what happens yeah we
tread carefully but she totally changed
my boss boss cause I'll show up so not
can you pick up the phone boss and call
so they can show up and stuff her we all
want to do it we would love to do it and
we run
we're grateful that people want it to
happen here that's what's left when you
get to work with your tribe I mean
that's just dope you know that is done
yeah yeah when you get to do it so I
mean when you have two seasons and then
you go wow to be able to possibly do
another season or a movie or whatever it
would be and spend all that time
together and enjoy it yeah that's that's
exceptional
[Music]